now as we await the release of this
report the house they are continuing
their existing impeachment inquiry of
Joe Biden and according to the
transcript of one witness and their
interview obtained by justthenews.com
that's John Solomon's group an employee
of a hospital company that Joe's brother
Jim worked with said she had no idea at
all what Jim did for the company or why
he was paid now another former Biden
associate testified that he loaned Jim
Biden $800,000 but only got half the
money back according to the Daily call
caller and the next week another one of
Hunter's old business associates Tony
babal Linsky guess what he's going to
share his story with lawmakers about the
big guy who at the very latest house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
is with us sir welcome back let me ask
you about this case um you have released
the transcript of this woman her name is
Carol Fox the trustee who represented
americore a now bankrupt health care
company
and she said she couldn't determine what
role James Biden played nor identify any
paperwork backing up any loans made to
him from a company struggling in 2018
she's the trustee of the EST of the
bankruptcy estate and she has now sued
Joe's brother James and sued him in 2022
because he didn't re repay the 600,000
in loans and she couldn't identify the
services that were allegedly
provided um and she found no documentary
evidence for consulting or marketing at
all what what's going on here that
sounds like being paid for doing
nothing yeah well there's a pattern of
that and we've been calling it influence
pedaling this is a perfect example Jim
Biden found out about americor health a
company that was a distressed healthc
care company that were that was on the
verge of bankruptcy he approached them
and said that because he's Joe Biden's
brother that he can go to the Middle
East and use all of Joe Biden's cont
contacts and get americore health all
the money they needed but they needed to
pay him first and the way he wanted to
be paid was through a loan now the
company went bankrupt Jim Biden like he
normally does never delivered on
anything other than you know committed
Securities fraud with this americore
health and the now bankrupt company uh
with the trustee testified they looked
over everything they saw the $600,000
that went to Jim Biden but they can't
find any loan doc and they can't find
one single thing that he did to get the
money and Sean the most important thing
about this for our investigation is they
paid Jim Biden in increments the last
increment was a $200,000 payment the
exact same day Jim Biden received that
$200,000 payment he had about $4,000 in
his account so that made it
$24,000 that same day he W he wrote a
check to Joe Biden for $200,000 that
proved Joe Biden benefited fin
financially from his family's Shady
influence pedaling scheme well that's
what's going to make Tony balin's
deposition I think that much more
critical have you had any evidence in
recent interviews that warrant your
committee to subpoena Joe's Financial
accounts and Records his pseudonim email
accounts have you gotten all of of that
information and what about any phones
that he used that might have been his or
maybe Rose mon
what do you know what do we know about
Joe's further involvement and when do
you get to actually get get the
information you've been seeking now for
a long time about Joe Biden the big guy
himself well did you know we've been
putting this taste together we've been
taking it step by step we've made sure
every eyes dotted and te's crossed and
that's why when Hunter Biden you know uh
uh had other plans for for coming in I I
think that's why he's now decided he's
going to come in for a sit down
deposition uh with respect to the the
phone records we've requested specific
phone records we've requested as you
know the pudm emails and the White House
continues to obstruct Sean it looks like
we're going to be headed to court very
soon for a lot of things pertaining to
Joe Biden it's like they've uh the the
Biden legal team is retreated uh on
things with Hunter that we've requested
they've retreated on things with Jim
Biden and other Biden family members and
some of their assoc but when it comes to
Joe Biden the fort is up uh they're
they're armed uh they're going to do
everything they can to continue this
obstruction because they're obviously
hiding
something yeah well I'd like to know
when we're going to get that information
let's talk about upcoming VI uh
interviews you have with James Biden uh
Joe's brother and with Hunter Biden um
okay what do you expect out of those
interviews and what are you looking
for well we have a lot of questions as
you know we have the bank records for
both Hunter Biden and Jim Biden and we
have a lot of questions there are a lot
of loans in there we've already
discussed with Kevin Morris a few weeks
ago when we interviewed him uh about all
the loans he gave to Hunter Biden over
$6 million in loans to Hunter Biden you
mentioned two loans to to Jim Biden in
when you were introducing me that's a
million dollars to Jim Biden we don't we
haven't found any loan documentation uh
it appears that the bidens may have been
laundering uh through the the the term
loan you know when you get a loan you
don't have to report that on your taxes
but a loan is something you're supposed
to pay back if you get a loan and you do
not pay it back then that's income
that's income in the form of either a
gift of the of the person that Lo money
or income from the person that receive
the money and and by the way if it's an
extended period of time that you're
paying back the loan don't you by as a
matter of law have to charge interest
otherwise it's considered a gift yeah
you do you do in the interest that's
just another another uh tool in the
toolbx look they have not produced any
loan documentation who would loan people
millions of dollars and not have a
document I mean th this is classic
influence pedaling this is a way they
tried to deceive the IRS and uh you know
subvert the the closure laws that are
required for immediate family members of
high ranking politicians this stinks to
high heaven we're going to continue to
bring these people in we've got Jim
Biden Hunter Biden and Tony balinski all
coming in in the next three weeks it'll
be a big three weeks for the
investigation I'd like to know what the
grand kids did to get the money they got
and where that money went anyway James
comr thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else